Fox News contributor Raymond aroyo is
with us Rey have you been monitoring the
media reaction to this terrorist attack
in Israel now I have been Laura and it's
it's startling it's actually quite
dangerous because it's the way that the
media is characterizing this surprise
attack by Hamas on civilians in Israel
listen closely boy they wish that those
same Israelis who were out there
protesting the so-called judicial
reforms would be protesting Israel's
inhumane treatment of the Palestinians
who live under Israeli occupation you've
got 2.2 million people crowded into 141
square miles so they automatically
become the victims of Israeli air stries
and it's basically like living Alex in
an open air prison the prime minister of
Israel the most right-wing in its uh
history the most farri extremist Jewish
nationalist Jewish supremacist
government that has existed in Israel
the rhetoric that has come out from
Israeli politicians towards the
Palestinians in the West Bank over the
past several months has been vile has
been disgusting
yeah I I wonder if it's been as vile as
slaughtering civilian women and children
I mean look there's no justification
lore for the kind of barbarity and
Slaughter of innocent people civilians
they're at home they're outside at
concerts and these guys are parachuting
in and shooting teenagers in the back
raping children rounding them up and
women these are not the acts of a
legitimate government I'm sorry and this
is an outrage that they're trying to
frame it that way and and the journal
just did this unbelievable
uh piece investigation of what um Iran
has been doing over the last several
weeks to help plan this with Hamas and
and Kirby's asked about this like well
we don't really have anything to say we
don't have anything to say about that
like how does how does the Wall Street
Journal know about this yeah but
everybody else is clueless Laura CNN
wasn't much better Christiana manur she
was pouring it on thick with a battalion
of pro Hamas spokesman starting with
this guy who's talking about Hamas but
uring
civilians what other choice did they
have do you condemn what Hamas did
inside Israel to Israeli civilians they
are dead and there are hostages first
and foremost the Western media must
really abandon this framework that has
gotten us to where we are today okay the
fact that Israel is an occupying power
the fact that Israel has violated
international law and Palestinian
rights it's really unbel aable or it's
like that you'd swear they're dealing
and talking about Canada and the United
States the people in Gaza elected Hamas
it's the Muslim Brotherhood it's an
offshoot of the Muslim Brotherhood it's
a terrorist organization that is their
government of course this was going to
happen and now Iran is pulling their
strings and the blood and the Bloodshed
follows but to justify this in any way
if they want to protest the land and
contested land fine find a diplomatic
solution kill children and women is not
way they're making justification for
this uh Raymond I was in stot in ashalon
in 2006 I think it was 2006 2007 um for
my radio show back then and it was
always it was so precarious being in in
stote where the Kasam Rockets would you
know kind of you know they were kind of
weren the most sophisticated Rockets but
they were coming across and they did
damage they killed people and the
proximity of being next to Gaza that
close with the IDF uh when we were there
it it it was chilling you felt it you
felt the tension we have a little
breaking news um special counsel Robert
her has spent the last two days
interviewing Joe Biden related to those
classified documents he had in Delaware
and in his office in DC that's breaking
news how much you want to bet Biden
doesn't remember a whole lot and his
most frequented word is probably anyway
I got to go well why didn't they just
say that I mean we were railing against
Biden not appearing on campus why campus
on on camera why didn't he just say that
Raymond thank you that was the lid the
lid was because he was being interviewed
by the special Council again they can't
they can't be honest that's it for us
tonight hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else